[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: When everybody
first discovers Kubernetes,
it feels like an
end unto itself,
where you could do so many
things with Kubernetes.
And as you become more
comfortable with Kubernetes,
what you realize
is it's actually
just a stepping stone to
so many other solutions
and possibilities.
You look at the power behind
it, a solution like Anthos,
for example, it
really encapsulates
all of Google's
learnings at scale
to how we help
customers experience
the same benefits and
value and all of the things
that the cloud-native
landscape has to offer,
but in a way that is
explicitly curated by Google's
expertise in the space.
Kubernetes is the level playing
field for all those things.
It's essentially a
platform that empowers
infinite possibilities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]